I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark
that's what time
welcome back to my hilarious 'ti series
of terrible video game adaptations I've
already covered do a Dead or Alive
leading up to Assassin's Creed in
December and now we're going to talk
about House of the Dead
directed by Uwe Boll director known for
a lot of video game adaptations don't
know the guy personally so I'm not going
to say anything about him personally but
his movies are not the greatest and
we're going to talk about House of the
Dead
oh-ho
so House of the Dead was based off of
the Light Gun arcade game I played it
quite a bit as a kid in movie theater
chains it was made by Sega it was a lot
of fun it was just fine for what it was
and for whatever reason somebody sitting
at a table somewhere probably wearing a
suit that was a little too tight for him
and he was probably choking a little bit
causing the blood circulation to not
quite go to his brain said hey house the
dead should be a movie and we should get
that kind of directed and somebody made
a phone call and it actually happened
and this film was released in theaters
despite the fact that it looks worse
than a made-for-tv movie on the sci-fi
channel seriously I mean this movie
looks so terrible it is basically like
he took the camera and pointed it at
somebody and said okay cut and then
pointed at somebody else okay cut and
then point over there okay
cut and then pointed over there like
that's the movie that's it
there isn't a single thing of artistic
value in this film let's start talking
about it the opening credits of this
movie represent the worst that
electronic music has to offer as well as
visual effects that look like they were
from the 80s kind of like when computer
effects were first invented and they
were trying things like experimenting
and similar to the game it opens with a
very cheesy narration that tells us
everything we need to know about the
characters wear it like fades in to
somebody you get some random narrator
talking about them and then there's no
other attempt to give these people a
form of characterization or something
that we can care about or latch on to
it's just hey this is this guy and he
does this and here's that girl and she's
kind of a sex object and here's that
girl and she's also kind of a sex object
oh and there's that girl and guess what
she's a sex object too we'll talk more
about the fact that virtually every
female character in this movie except
for maybe one is just there
you have boobs the direction in this
movie as I said resembles a really bad
McDonald's commercial where it's just
people standing around and they're
talking about shit and someone's filming
them so here's the plot of the movie
okay this is one of the best parts every
character here is going to this island a
very deserted island that no one wants
to go to they can't find a single person
to boat them there no one wants to take
them there because of this legend that
there's something spirit istic or
there's like a death surrounding this
island yet a big rave has been planned
there and somehow people are already
there with a giant Sega banner no less
over their party because that's what
everyone puts up at their raves Sega
banners the next time I have a party I'm
just gonna hang a big Nintendo sign and
everyone can just dance underneath a
Nintendo sign and celebrate the wonder
of Nintendo but let me get back to this
extreme logical flaw so no one wants to
take anyone to this island boaters
refuse to take anybody there our
characters have to give this boating
captain a grand to take them to this
island one thousand dollars and he
finally says yes how did all of these
people for this rave get to the island
with all of that equipment if no one
wants to take anybody there whoops
you're going to a rave with all these
drunk people and you have over a
thousand dollars in cash in your wallet
these characters are dumb and that's not
the first dumb thing they do trust me it
continues from there this movie is
filled with the most abysmal flat
lifeless humor that I've seen in some
time this is a movie about zombies on
the island and everybody shoots them in
the head this should be a really fun
movie there is none of that to be had in
this film none of it so next we go over
to the island and there's a couple there
that we have never been introduced to
and they're just like hey here's some
characters in this movie it's a girl
swimming and a guy who kind of just
wants to flop and lay on the beach while
she swims right after she takes off her
clothes of course and we get a lot of
shots underneath the water at her legs
and some music that resembles a film
that I
love
could you possibly have been more
blatant and your ripoff of the opening
scene of Jaws I mean is it even possible
to be even more obvious it's like he
even told the composer to sort of mimic
John Williams music so the girl from the
jaws ripoff scene is now searching for
her boyfriend because he disappeared and
she finds him and we get our first look
at the zombies
just about everything in that scene
reminded me of troll 2 it's almost like
a tribute to troll 2 oh my god and right
around here something else happens
something that blew my mind something
that just shook my world something that
just drained all of the blood from my
veins I just became a lifeless sack of
goo sitting watching this movie I swear
to you my body deflated I became a
little pus sack that's all I was
throughout this entire film they've
chosen to put insert shots of the actual
game during scene transitions
you couldn't possibly make a dumber
choice
you couldn't I genuinely believe there's
nothing dumber you could have done
insert shots from the game now I
mentioned there's a police boat
following them every time we cut back to
this police boat all we get is ADR from
this woman I guarantee that actress was
nowhere near that boat it just pans over
the boat we get some narration of her
saying what's happening and then
eventually later her character actually
shows up we're supposed to somehow be
invested in this character despite the
fact that we've never seen her we just
have heard her voice a lot the
characters in this movie are the most
dull boring idiotic just fucking dumb
people you could possibly ever imagine
they're not even people okay
they're just cardboard they're like
little pieces of paper just kind of
floating around the frames and they just
so happen to be humans this is one of
the only times I've watched a movie this
bad where I actually start to feel
empathy for the actors I genuinely feel
sorry for them in this movie every time
a character says something remotely
smart some dumb person just changes the
topic instantly I think something Bad's
happened here hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo like what
we're on the island where the wave of
the year supposed to be happening but
it's completely deserted yeah it wears
me it worries me there won't be mixers
Simon cannot survive on but alone
because we wouldn't want the characters
to do anything smart they would possibly
make us appreciate them or relate to
them in some way that would be bad think
of my rain why don't we
go somewhere we will get way too late my
god I hate this movie real talk here
every shot in this movie appears
unplanned it really does it honestly
feels like there isn't a single thing
storyboarded there's no plan it's just a
go over there okay it's good okay yep
cut all right um yeah I'll go over there
I'm gonna shoot you right there okay
very good yep cut all right that was
good want to check the gate we're done
another thing about this movie that is
just such a missed opportunity is that
these characters are on an island filled
with zombies that sounds really fun that
could be a really fun movie like if
Edgar Wright directed this movie it'd be
incredible
but who a ball seems to have no idea how
to build suspense this film progresses
and things are just shown some really
fucked-up guy just steps on screen he's
got his skin is all sewn together and
stuff he's eventually revealed as like
the big bad guy but he just he just
literally just steps on the screen he's
just kind of like this
like I haven't seen a villain reveal
that bad since jaws the revenge when the
sharp just appears on the screen in flow
closeup for the very first time you ever
see him so next they run into people who
have encountered the zombies and a play
of video they recorded on a camera that
shows the zombies just eating people at
the rave rather than let the video
provide terror or suspense they just
talk over it and explain everything
imagine the disturbing footage scene in
signs where Merrill sees the alien on
the news videotape imagine if he just
sat there going oh this is where the
alien comes by oh man these people had
no idea what they were gonna deal with
all these poor kids that birthday party
they really weren't expecting that were
they it's it's like that it is all
suspense that could possibly be in this
scene is just drained from it it's
potentially a good idea of finding a
video camera with footage showing the
zombies first attack it's just it
literally just shows women flashing the
camera with their tits and he's like oh
whoops let me fast-forward through that
I'm like so the one character in this
movie I was almost sort of kind of
getting close to maybe relating to
earlier this girl who was questioning
things and people were like no forget
about it
now after seeing the video of the zombie
attack she just thinks it's a joke she
thinks it's a practical joke so their
old friend who disappeared earlier now
reappears as a zombie and she gets blown
away by the police boat captain who up
until now was just a dr without a face
in fact you know what she's still a dr
right now i just want to get you all as
far away from here as possible just
don't know what to say but you know the
best part of this scene is the reaction
of the girl who just witnessed her best
friend die she's like a wild animal
did you see her face oh my god it's
horrible I just can't right now so now a
bunch of zombies climb up the captain's
boat and he basically just stands in one
position pivots at at 360 and shoots
them all a bunch of times
with some really great music
I mean it's definitely the best music
choice that could have made and don't
tell me some music from the game because
I already know that's the style they're
going for as I said I used to play this
game it's a game this is a film there
should be some differences again there's
no suspense
it's just how bored were you just
watching me do that imagine watching an
entire film and that's all that happens
so as the characters are getting close
to where the boat is they're kind of
starting to believe that some serious
shit is going on and they scream for
this guy who just so happens to be named
Captain Kirk by the way
oh yeah no shit guys that's definitely
not him I just don't know what to say
and what is this zombie doing just just
grabbing people aggressively this is
like a goosebumps episode where no one's
allowed to die because it's for kids
like it's kind of famous the goosebumps
episodes on the TV show there's only a
couple that have a legit body count for
the most part you can't kill anybody
they can like grab people and like kind
of like shake their shoulders and stuff
there can't be any blood or whatever
these are goosebumps zombies they just
kind of grab people and go like are
sorry just turn into a horse apparently
I used to play this game okay I get it
you shoot a lot of zombies over and over
and over as they slowly walk towards you
that makes four zero suspense in a film
it was suspenseful in the game because
you're like oh shit I just dropped a
dollar of quarters into this thing I
really don't want to die right now I
want to keep playing and they keep
coming and they keep coming and that's
what added the suspense of the game this
movie has nothing like that because I
can just press fast-forward if I really
- I wish I had now they show a fucking
flashback to explain the zombie outbreak
on this island and apparently this guy
is the weird guy with the sown skin did
you really have to explain the zombie
outbreak it could have just been
ambiguous it just kind of seems like
they make every wrong choice honestly
it's like the things that they should
try harder on they don't the things that
they don't have to worry so much about
like explaining where the zombies came
from they feel the need to explain it
work harder on the other shit Bowl also
uses the exact same angle of zombies
running back and forth across some trees
with what is supposed to be moonlight
but it's probably just a big-ass spot
like he cuts to this angle so many times
you can tell that he stood there with
his camera told multiple actors or maybe
even just one for all I know to run back
and forth over and over again so you
could have multiple takes of zombies
running but it's the same angle we're
not idiots we can see this shit so next
I just I just want you to look at the
scene and just realize that literally at
least 45 percent of the movie is exactly
like this
feel like jumping from a tall structure
yet too bad or not done yet
so when characters die in this movie
they do a 360 pivot and fade to red like
in the game I want the next James Bond
movie I want James Bond to die and I
want red blood to drip down the screen
and I wanted to play this music so next
the characters just happen across an
ammo dump so we can get a big gigantic
shootout scene let's talk about this
scene
it's unbelievably incompetent this
entire sequence is a herpes inducing
eyesore a parasitic leech of a scene
that has the effect of causing one to
long for medical anesthesia a
never-ending barrage of matrix ripoffs
amateur camera work and unforgivably
bland rap music I'm to believe that
every one of these idiots is a combat
veteran who never needs to reload their
weapon oh that was therapeutic so I
thought that sequence was terrible as
this sequence is coming to a close our
guy who I guess is sort of becoming the
main character actually has a flashback
to the scene we just saw
what the hell was that what was that
what in this movie I mean I thought it
was dumb but then that happened so
something I haven't talked about this
guy is apparently an underwear model yep
that's pretty much his character when
his cheek gets mangled he refers to
himself as Elephant Man am i honestly
supposed to care about this
self-centered human piece of shit look
at me who's gonna be able to look me in
the eyes with a face like this freak I
belong in the fucking circus what a
great message for anyone who watches
this movie who deals with any type of
self-consciousness
so there's so little to talk about they
find gunpowder zombies try to break in
the idiots hide they use the gunpowder
to blow stuff up and I guess this guy
won't have to live his Elephant Man
anymore yeah he just had to die cuz that
horrible face injury too is cheap so
more random people die then they meet
one of the three musketeers in a tunnel
uh okay and just when I thought that was
kind of funny it's actually not one of
the Three Musketeers
I wish it was oh man that'd be so great
it's their other friend from earlier but
wait it's not that guy it's actually
that guy hiding as a friend dressed as
one of the Three Musketeers
you can't make this shit up and then
once again speak the plot out loud by
letting us know what this guy wants to
do you created us you could be immortal
why
do I even have to say anything could I
just I just leave it at that
do you guys understand the absurdity of
that dialogue I'm just gonna trust that
my viewers get how dumb that is because
you guys are smart
you created it all so you could become
immortal why to live forever you would
say it
so another horrific sequence breaks out
this time it's a sword fight I can only
pray it's the last so the guy who runs
up and fucking chops off the zombies
head
why didn't you just do that earlier then
a helicopter shows up and it's like
predator who the helicopter comes and
saves the guy because he's the big hero
I guess and his reaction to being saved
is genuinely compassionate when you
we're here to rescue no thanks
this is our main character you got a
last name
Kurian oh shit that's a character from
the game Wow I remember playing the
arcade game with the movie theater and
that's carryin a no-no who fucking cares
it's bad
you all knew that it's one of the worst
movies ever made it has like a 2 out of
10 on IMDB or some shit I don't know
it's bad oh I think I'm still going to
talk about some more video game movies
leading up to assassin's creed I wonder
what the next one might be guys thank
you so much as always for watching if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
you